you went to Australia with comedy bang
bang
how many bang bang and you went there
and and you took you came back with some
pictures yeah well okay we went to
Australian I was so excited to go cuz
I'd never been but the only thing I
really cared about doing was like
meeting a koala and so I forced the guys
to go with me to go to a Koala Sanctuary
and we get we got to hold them and it
was really special and what was it about
holding a koala that was so special I
burst into tears the second I held it
because it was like a baby and I don't
know why that is anything but it really
knows we have a picture of you bursting
into tears holding the Koala I was so
happy that was like the best day ever
it doesn't look like the best day ever
what about I think you you also wanted
to see an ostrich yes I got to take a
selfie with an ostrich and it was really
pissed about it I think we have a
picture it's ready to attack didn't
attack you with oh no it did a tax [ __ ]
Scott Aukerman though it got on the head
he was taking a picture and the thing
just went like straight down on him
right so yeah they can kill you those
they could oh they really can yeah like
something they can really pick and kick
you to death yes yeah they can rip your
heart out yeah with their claws I'm
making this part out I'm pull it out of
your chest and show it to you yeah and
then eat it while you're still alive
you